[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un couteau mois quand ils étaient aux
filles de jeunes à dire qu'en octobre
destinée
ça me rappelle qu'un jour j'y étais le
camp près du grand yaka un bon vivant un
gros croit fin un peu dans le vide et lé
mandat à des maps ou une excuse pour
attitude jeu vient troubler tour où ma
femme je m'en doutais tu vas me dire que
le grand yaka me demande tu es
prodigieux titus tu devines toujours
tout en effet le grand yaka tu attends
impatiemment l'ofs monseigneur hongrois
banc ou voilà nive et oui je ne
s'accompagne pas tu connais le chemin
même petitdidier sa part craint bonjour
grands lacs
dis moi qui tu style qu'est ce que tu
aimes la facture aux adore la peinture
surtout la femme de robert je veux dire
à lui à 8 ans et plus les bons meirieu
alors voilà j'ai le cul tu fait
supporter alors ceci cela alors j ai
qu'occuper vous de titus et les hippies
ne regarde pas je ne je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas fait de partout de ma vie
alors tu sais comme un jury fera
doucement doucement il me faut du
matériel demeure avant de faire des
tableaux un litre d'huile et de la
teinture voilà tu veux que je veux que
tu me fasses tribaux fait une très
ressemblants coiteux très naturelle
comme comme je suis là toi et comptait
sur moi même ou soigner à lui
[Musique]
il faut bien mélanger j'ai entendu deux
titres au a pas fait arrêtons le vitro
avec android app stores est meilleur il
est prêt n'est pas la belliqueuse
mayonnaise le quitus qu'est ce que nous
faisons tu commun sur une heure sous ce
mandat dans ma taille elle est pour tes
vous vous vous coûter l'inspiration
voyons voyons maillot visas aux rondes
armes pointues signaux particuliers
mais on sait bien comme ça si si j'vous
ai mal pas mal ne vous ai pas s'il vous
plaît c'est que je vais être très utile
soyez tranquille vous allez ta tv vous
arrivez en commun je vois je vois tu as
sont en train de commettre une erreur et
le grand yaka vous que je pas son
contrat alors tu sais mais ouais ouais
ouais très bien orienté très bien on est
avec vous en prie aidez moi
bon je sens qu'il te feront attention at
au 10 octobre
voilà une idée en apparel de proton
serait bientôt fini titus en un clin
d'oeil c'est instantané
8 m sortez la photographie la voix toute
éthique t'énerve pas titus il faut la
déplie heures on dirait qu'il va parler
d'eux a été dépêchée toile je veux voir
mon comportement
vous pouvez en avoir il est terminé
merci entre jonathan reis des artistes
dont le besoin
au revoir picasso alaoui a séché d'evry
ça donne mondiale et pottas lui oui je
suis vos seins que je suis bon à part ça
je suis magnifique et je suis mal à
situer une très grande artiste
ainsi 6 6 1 6 6 un vrai match je suis
content de toi tu veux vraiment été un
brillant moi je suis pour que je suis
bourg vous voyez la peinture à l'huile
bref c'est pas du bitume et après après
c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]